all right well where are you for the
globes you were in prague right are you
there now
i am i'm still in prague okay so what
time is it
uh it's only 10 45 pm
okay so we are still at this moment
hours from the critics choice awards
starting what's your plan do you have
coffee
maybe my plan is that this lovely dior
top
has uh snaps and as soon as i'm done
with you
guess what put the pajamas on for a
little while
lie down okay
so you stay awake with quick naps and
giving yourselves
fashion breaks i tried that during the
globes but i had a pin
that was facing directly towards my
skull and
i couldn't take it out or lie down or i
would have been a lobotomy i think is
the word
do you have anyone there with you to
wake you up though or do you rely on the
alarm clock
ah no no no i'm uh i'm all alone no
hotel room
so it would be yes i i have to put my
phone on the other side of the room
that's such a good tip and set like sick
well you look gorgeous so you're wearing
dior tell me what it's been like
to work the fashions for these zoom
awards shows
oh my gosh the photographers have come
and everybody gets tested beforehand and
we do photo shoots and hallways and
we everybody does their best and hope
that we come up
with an image that actually does the
outfit
and made some service
and then uh yes you looked gorgeous at
the globes i love it so you pretty much
have the whole hotel for yourself for
photoshop basically
yeah basically okay so can you get so
this is dior is this a dress is this
this is so it's not
it's actually i can give you it's a
really uh
it's uh i don't know what you can see um
ant suit
and it's got this stripe kind of a
tuxedo stripe
it's got this top thing it's kind of
very cool right that was a true jaw drop
no joke that is amazing
it's a very very cool we thank you
because i miss the fashions i
i think we all do so thank you for
serving some looks for us to
get the feet for the eyes truly no
problem
they've got some very cool dior jewels
here too that are really
kind of that's kind of i like these guys
are these custom for you
no no no no no no the piece just
but they are dior and the shoes
well how will you feel if you win
tonight at the critics choice award i
know you're going to say how will you
feel if you don't win
this evening well uh
i will be i will uh i mean
it was very funny after the gloves
because you know you're done you do all
these you know
interviews afterwards and it's like
goodbye and
and then you're just in my hotel room
time to go to bed and you didn't even
have a globe right so
you didn't even have a goat i had some
sushi okay it was 5 am
and i had some sushi anyway tonight i
am uh what am i doing i don't know i'll
take a bath
i'll take a bath i'll i'll say woohoo
and uh pat myself on the back
oh it's it's oh i'm sure i'll get some
um some phone calls from people who are
in you know time zones where they're
supposed to be awake
yeah well how has it been because
one of my favorite things about red
carpets at award shows is you see these
casts
all come together again and for the
crown you have several nominees but you
aren't able to be together
how has that felt and how have you all
been staying in touch
i well it we had big plans
uh of how we were gonna do it and then
somehow
throughout the whole thing we didn't at
least last time
and uh i i assumed that we'd all be
facetiming each other during you know
um no it's weird it's a weird thing the
whole thing is just very
bizarre um well probably i mean we were
all texting each other when when
you know when everybody we're all
texting each other and
and uh so that's nice but it is it is
sad not to get to be
in the same room and have a laugh and
and properly
cheer each other on and ah well i love
your
speech at the globes because you did
seem so genuinely
kind of taken aback by the splendor of
the moment how has this felt has it sunk
in yet that you want a globe for the
show
i don't know even a few days later i
don't feel like it
did i actually i jumped on the phone
with an um
this woman connie freiburg who used to
be my uh
manager for like 20 years and like two
days later
we were on the phone together it was
somehow it was talking to her
who had been at other globes with me she
was the one who would go with me
wearing the same dress every single time
she
she yeah she had her own web page
and she is somewhat talking to her it
actually reminded me
how uh you know that it had happened
and how wonderful it was and and it
might have been 20 years
since i had last glove wednesday it was
partly
that as well so it was she kind of
brought it on
to me very cool well there was also this
response when you gave your speech a lot
of people
were saying wait does she have a british
accent and responding to that alec
baldwin even tweeted about it
what did you think of everyone
commenting on that well i didn't i don't
have
um social media on my phone so i wasn't
a couple people texted to say that
something was going on
um i mean i didn't pay any attention to
it because it's just something that i'd
live
i i grew up between two countries and
and so depending on who's in my ear
is which direction my accent goes and
uh and so i'm so used to it that uh
it's kind of old news for me so
i mean i've met alec before and i've met
you know and he's and so he said he was
gonna reach out to you about it
uh i i haven't heard from you it doesn't
matter i mean it's it's so it's so
not a newsworthy item but i i'm
i'm sad that it caused him so much
distress
well i loved your speech again it was
one of those
it was such a beautiful moment because i
really felt like i was i
want to sound weird i felt like i was in
your hotel room with you you seemed so
happy and then taken aback what's it
like to give
an acceptance speech over zoom you know
it's actually a lot less um uh stressful
oh good okay well getting up there in
front of
um that room whether that room is the
golden globe room or the sangram or
whatever it is is
is unbelievably intimidating
and um and uh you know
uh it's it's intense and so i
you know to be able to sit in a hotel
room and sit on a sofa
and be alone and not see the hundreds of
people or thousands of people who may be
watching is
kind of a cool gig well my last question
for you
uh of course the real royals harry and
megan having a big
interview airing what do you think will
you be watching it they watch the crown
do they uh uh what when is this
happening
uh today weirdly at the same time as the
critics choice award oh wow
uh okay well then no if it's at the same
time as the critics choice
i shall be watching it um
well what what will um what will you
look back on this whole experience as i
mean we've loved watching you play
margaret thatcher and i just love that
you're getting the accolades
so well deserved for it how will you
kind of remember this role you think
years from now and
being on this awards show journey with
it now um
well i mean it was it it was
such an incredible experience from from
the very beginning until the very end
it's a a really wonderful production to
be a part of and
i i've heard many people say that it's
their favorite job
ever there's something about you feel
very held and
respected and no matter who
you are or what your your past is in
terms of the work you've done or whether
you're brand new
to the industry it's really a very
special project
and there's not you know a single person
on it in the years that has been going
that has brought
drama or you know it's just it runs
smoothly and
quietly and effortlessly although
i'm sure they don't think so i'm sure
anybody sleeps and uh but it's
it was amazing and i feel very uh
pleased and proud
and privileged and um and i wish i could
do it again
ah well you were you're amazing in it
thank you so much for your time
i have to wrap with you but really
quickly you mentioned the shoes and i
don't know if we'll get to see them so
can you show me the shoes
i can look at that that's just
classic and gorgeous i know oh just
beautiful
what really quick what's faster getting
ready uh to sit in your own hotel room
for an awards show or getting ready for
the actual show in
regular life definitely to sit in your
hotel room
i mean i don't actually have to be
dressed from the waist down
i'm glad i was so that i could stand up
and show you my outfit but you know
well jillian we thank you for committing
thank you so much you're amazing and
thanks for your time uh
good luck with the naps and the coffee
thank you i appreciate it
bye everybody thank you